hey guys what's up here's my friend Jake
he's been in a bunch of our movies
usually behind a ghost mask anyways Jake
knows we had all our guns in a big pile
he's like guys that's no good
you gotta store your guns in a classy
way so he built us a gun rack come check
it out go for it let's see it show Jake
pretty sweet so you got your Nek pull
their jobs your mp40 you're just a dog
on the planet your m fours
yeah metas Glocks so you use airsoft
guns for majority of our props here's
all our pistols most of them are metal
gas blowback to get the best effect we
have good metal guns to use for
close-ups in the camera and we have
crappy plastic ones like this which are
used for dropping oh no we got classic
historical YouTube filmmaking props here
diamond pickaxe signed by notch himself
you guys might remember this shotgun
from cheats in real life
DeStorm used it also little-known fact
nerf guns make really good sci-fi
weapons when you repaint them this is a
nerf Firefly that we used in prison all
decked out with Sam showing off his
sweet spray paint skills also you know
it's really sweet nerf guns have
standard size rails so you take airsoft
gear stick em on nerf guns like a sweet
nerf long shot right here which now
looks like a nerf laser cannon forget
our collection em fors m16s actually
they're all in force
um this is Freddy's this is actually
used by ghosts and frozen crossing to my
favorite gun in the bunch is probably
the sniper rifle which is actually used
by Punisher for the bullet hits tutorial
[Music]
what's your favorite gun cowboy revolver
baby all right
what is my favorite gun it's either this
one of this one this one's huge this was
the Tomb Raider guns to KP 45 match and
also this one I mean come on it
sawed-off shotgun how can you not like
that alright so the other side of the
room is pretty rad though we got a all
our miscellaneous stuff here this is
where we keep like scopes accessories
clips straps got cowboy hats
we got military hats gloves woo what's
this ooh pretty much enough outfits to
suit an army Freddie's friends sure went
set up the clothing rack for us to help
us with that and Jake thank you for
setting up the gun rack as this is sweet
I love the UH though the whole motorized
thing so it can spin yeah
my favorite vehicles oh yeah the biggest
problem is people come in here see all
the guns to get scared so we have a good
hider